I think the word entrepreneur is bandied
about too loosely does that make me a
troll if you think so awesome I don't
think so great who cares who cares
there are probably too many bad
businesses getting started and not
enough good ones rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day I've right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
figure out if you're an entrepreneur
over to you simon Sinek also if you want
to know what simon and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check that my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you get the
benefit of hearing what everybody else
has to think before you render your
opinion what guarantee do I have that
your stuff will work which my answer was
none it's like a hammer you can use it
broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool
[Music]
I think the word entrepreneur is bandied
about too loosely mm that not everyone
who owns a small business as an
entrepreneur there are small business
owners and they're entrepreneurs what's
known as pretty and you can find
entrepreneurs in big companies it
doesn't means that they're small
business owners right I think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers I
think rather than risk takers yeah I
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers I think who are an
entrepreneur there's a risk taker of
your small business owner right you went
out to start the business but they're
not the same
I don't think and entrepreneurs are
those ones who they're constantly
looking to solve problems and that's
where I think they perceive opportunity
or the mischief that you describe I
don't think it's I don't think
inherently it's a sense of mischief
they're not trying to stir the pot for
the sake of stirring the pot I think
that they see something and they're like
we can make that better or we can fill
that hole and that's very much the way
the famous entrepreneurs the Elon Musk's
and the Richard Branson's operate they
see gaps they see things that don't work
as their jobs as did jobs they see
things that could be better or they mean
Elon Musk was just interviewed by Chris
Anderson at Ted last week and Chris
Anderson and sort of near the end of the
interview it's online go watch it it's
really great Chris Anderson asks Elon
Musk's something to the effect of why
are you doing all these things like why
do you just stick with Tesla and be done
with it like why do all the other stuff
and you look at and musk you can see
this look on his face and he takes a
long time to answer he actually doesn't
understand the question he cannot
understand why you wouldn't do that and
he sort of gets him Phatak which mean
lon musk is pretty amazing cuz he
doesn't get him Phatak but that's
basically what it is he get some fat
again says cuz I want to live in a world
that's better than this swear words to
that effect you know where I'm not where
the world that we're living right now
makes us unhappy why don't we want to
live in a world that makes us happy you
know he gets sort of he kind understand
and again it's vision first and that's
why he doesn't understand why you
wouldn't try and solve problems so some
small business owners are entrepreneurs
some aren't some people who work in
corporate are entrepreneurs some aren't
what is the definition of an
entrepreneur
who cares why spend time thinking about
the labels that people call themselves
if you think you're an entrepreneur
great you're an entrepreneur amazing
somebody else thinks you're not who
cares what they think
who cares if somebody thinks that you
are not an entrepreneur why does it
matter I don't understand why we spend
so much time thinking about the labels
that other people put on us honestly I
think it's just because you need
validation you need to feel like the
thing that you're doing is right you
need other people's validation of your
ideas of your labels of your identity
and that's a losing game you know I
played League of Legends I don't play a
lot I'm a silver for silver five player
am i a gamer sure now what no awesome
now what I like the main team Oh does
that make me a troll if you think so
awesome I don't think so great who cares
who cares how does this make your life
better if somebody else thinks that you
are an entrepreneur or not how does that
have any bearing on what you need to do
zero stop caring so much about other
people's validation it does not matter
this conversation holds you back from
actually taking action now I'm gonna
give you three ways and how to be
confident and need less validation from
other people number one is move from
what to why move from what you are what
label you identify as or what label
other people are trying to put on you
the what to the why why do you do what
you do not what are you I'm a white guy
I'm six feet tall I have some brown hair
I have brown who cares none of that
matters why do I do what I do that's
what gets me up in the morning making
videos for you guys I want to try to
solve the world's biggest problem that's
my why you can call it whatever you want
I don't care your what is not going to
hold me back from accomplishing my why
the why the why the why the why is so
much more important than the what what's
your why move from what to why step
number two is find your one word I think
it's one of the most important exercises
you can ever do in your life what is the
one word most important core value that
you stand for when you know what you
stand for
gives you a rock like you are standing
on a rock where there's quicksand all
around you other people's lives are
quicksand somebody else calls them a
label and they freak out and their life
collapses somebody says you're not an
entrepreneur and like your life is over
your entire life is based off of
quicksand I want you to stand on a rock
you are on a rock so that nobody can
push you from that rock no matter what
wind comes at you or what insult has
hurled your way whatever label somebody
tries to put on you it doesn't matter
cuz you're on a rock the world's on
quicksand and you are on a rock you get
it yet you're on a rock that's your one
word most important core value I'm about
belief you can hate believe you could
say believe is the worst thing of all
time a lot of people don't like believe
they don't like my messaging awesome
it's not gonna change what I think about
believe because it's at the core it's at
the core it's the rock it's at the core
of who I am and when you find that for
yourself when you understand what is at
the core of you as a human being you are
much less likely to be swayed by other
people's opinions and labels on you find
your one word and step number three is
inoculate yourself against judgement
anytime you feel yourself shrinking
playing small because of somebody else's
opinion of you then you have to go and
do that thing if you want to label
yourself something you want to call
yourself an entrepreneur but you work in
a big fortune 500 company if that's the
thing that is on your mind that is
messing with you right now that you want
to call yourself an entrepreneur but you
are a senior vice president at coca-cola
the best thing you can do if you
recognize it if you catch it that you
are unwilling to share it because of the
opinions of other people you want to
label yourself that but you're not doing
it because other people are judging you
you need to smash that out and you can
catch it most of the time you don't most
of the time we play small with by
default without ever noticing but if you
catch it you want to call yourself an
entrepreneur and most people think
you're not go and update every social
media bio of yours and put on your app
owner you want to call yourself a gamer
even though your silver for silver 5 at
League of Legends amazing go to
Instagram go to Twitter go to YouTube go
to LinkedIn update your bio to say
own it you are not allowed to play small
based off of other people's opinions and
judgments of you and you start
immediately in the small wins something
like that something like just updating
your Instagram bio to have the label
that you want to call yourself like if
you can't do that how are you going to
go off and accomplish your big goals
whatever big dream big goal big
aspirations big mission you have for
yourself
is going to come with a lot of
negativity a lot of judgment because
you're trying to change the way
something is done even looking at me I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem that's only positivity but
there's going to be people who hate on
it because it involves changing the way
some things are done
the people who love the status quo will
always fight against the people who want
to change it so you want to change it
you want to do some big thing and change
it that will never happen you will never
get the courage to do it if you can't do
something as simple as updating your
Instagram bio so I want you to knock you
let yourself against judgment as soon as
you feel it this is label you want to
call yourself but you're worried about
other people didn't you you have to do
it you had no option you have to do it
and train yourself because the next time
you're worried you'll do it again and
the next time you're worried you do it
again and again and again and again and
again and slowly you'll be able to hang
there bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger levels of judgment and
then the thing that seems so huge before
is nothing to you and allows you to go
off and actually go out and accomplish
your mission inoculate yourself against
judgment now I've got a really special
bonus slip that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know what
is one fear of judgment that you are
going to crush today leave it in the
comments below I'm curious to find out
my best business is you know solve
problems reduce stress make people's
lives easier because that's what we all
look for right in school you want to get
through class you want to get good
grades and you're looking for the best
way to do that when you start a business
you want to make your customers happy
you want to make it so that they don't
think about going anywhere else but
again you always got to think about your
own consumer experiences what is it
about what is it that you look for and
that tends to guide you
would you buy from your own company you
know and you got to be honest with
yourself because not all companies are
going to be great but my most successful
companies understand that I actually
think you should think twice before
starting certain types of businesses so
I think there are probably too many bad
businesses getting started and not
enough good ones
so that's it's you know I don't think
there's I don't think there's anything
about entrepreneurship per se that is
that is is good you know I was talking
one of my friends a few years ago I was
asking him what do you want to be doing
in five or ten years so it's really
clear I want to be an entrepreneur
that's like saying I want to be rich I
want to be famous and I don't think I
don't those are what those are good
things being rich and famous or they're
not good as direct goals like if you if
you have that as your sole goal you're
unlikely to I think really really
succeed and so I think you become an
entrepreneur because you're working on
an important problem nobody else is
working on I think you should start a
business if you have something if you're
if you're working on a problem that
otherwise would not get solved if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more simon Sinek I highly
recommend checking out the infinite game
video that we did on him it's right
there next to me go click it continue to
believe and I'll see you there when the
leader creates an environment in which
people feel that someone has my back
they will do extraordinary things
success is a feeling